- Joining us now is a pair of
boss ladies, identical twins,
Antoinette Clarke and Tricia Clarke-Stone.
Give it up for 'em, y'all.
(applause)
They're authors of a new book called
Double Down: Bet on Yourself
and Succeed on your Terms.
Welcome ladies, why did
you write this book?
And I'm so excited about reading it,
cause I just saw a couple
excerpts and I was like yes.
- Awesome.
- Yes.
- So, we wrote the book to
really democratize success
for people that look like us.
If we think about it, women make up
about 50% of the workforce,
but we're highly underrepresented
when it comes to executive roles.
And then, last year alone,
only 24 Fortune 500 Companies
were led by a female CEO.
That's just absurd to us.
- And 24, what's the total
number, like of Fortune 500?
- Yeah, Fortune 500, and out of that,
one was a woman of color.
So we wrote this book so
that we become the norm
and not that.
- Yes, normalize, normalize, I love that.
I love that.
So it's very, it's authentic,
and do you wanna talk too,
Antoinette, about what
- She's always hogging the space, Kelly.
- I love it, that's what siblings do.
- Let's give her some shine.
- You know it's taken us a long time
to get to where we are today,
and our book essentially debunks
a lot of status quo myths,
and we're tryin' to
really push that forward
so women understand that
they need to challenge them
so they can be boss ladies.
You don't need to be
an entrepreneur or CEO
to achieve boss lady
status, we all can do it.
- Absolutely, so what're some
myths you bust in the book?
- So the first is everyone cares
only about how hard you work.
But the truth is, people care
about how smart you work.
It's about achievement verse activity.
So you really wanna
focus on the milestones
and not the time.
And the way you do that
is to be strategic,
and really lean into clear
goals and objectives.
- I love that, I'm gonna be so much better
for reading this book, I can't wait.
So what's the next one?
- And the second myth is
basically people feel like
they should care only about
how well you do things
that are asked of you,
but the important thing is doing things
that aren't asked of you,
which sounds a little crazy,
but you have to go beyond your JD.
So beyond your job description,
and think of the long game.
- Exactly, like look, it might not be
in your job description,
but this thing the other
day wasn't in mine,
and you just do it cause
it needs to get done.
And that's what you want,
you just want it to get done.
- And that's what women do.
- I know!
- Right, yeah you had to.
- Yeah, yes.
- Your advice though, it
just isn't for working women.
- No.
- It's for all women, right?
Cause every woman doesn't wanna
become a corporate executive
or an entrepreneur, but what
we do want is to be celebrated
and respected for who we are.
- Moms that stay at home?
I mean, I would take any
other job in the world,
like, and I have children,
but it is hard to constantly be just,
responsible for molding this human 24/7,
and you're just at home, and you can't,
you lose your identity,
there's all so much going on.
So I think this book isn't just for people
in any kind of industry,
it's for any person.
Like any woman really
trying to find the best part
of you and be the best
you that you can be.
- Absolutely, it's the
best version of yourself.
- Well moms are the CEO's of households.
- Right, right.
- They're the ultimate boss lady.
- Yes, yes.
- I make my husband step up though, y'all,
I'm like, and luckily I
married a true cowboy,
he does that on his own, so.